in the wake of covet 19 companies have
accelerated their digital transformation
to support their employees working from
home this has brought a huge concern for
cyber security 72 of security and i.t
professionals admit that skill gaps
exist on their current teams and 65
agreed that it poses a concerning threat
to their businesses that's why udacity
has launched the enterprise security
nanodegree program to help you excel
further in network security and close
the skills gap within your business
you'll be able to dive into real-world
projects led by our industry
professionals and get hands-on
experience in building a secure
enterprise network such as s-i-e-m
design a security baseline conduct a
security assessment which consists of
vulnerability scanning threat modeling
code review and so much more our
programs include access to udacity
student hub where you can connect with
other learners as well as our career and
mentor services to help you prepare for
success with these new skill sets you
can be a competitive asset to the
enterprise security market and be job
ready as you'll be able to build a
portfolio that can be showcased to
future employers
get the in-demand skills of enterprise
security by enrolling in udacity's
enterprise security nanodegree program
and start your journey today